Here's something interesting.
2020 Democratic presidential candidate Elizabeth
Warren has now taken the lead
in a new CBS primary pole, not nationally,
but specifically in the state of New Hampshire,
which is an important primary state.
It's the second to vote in the primary season
after Iowa is caucus.
So let's dig into this particular primary
today and talk about the polling and some
of the dynamics that are going on.
So yes, the poll is within the margin of error
or Elizabeth Warren, 27 Joe Biden 26 Bernie
Sanders, 25 but the momentum is really with
Elizabeth Warren in New Hampshire.
If you think back to late May, early June,
that's just a few months ago.
She was in fourth place in New Hampshire,
polling about 8% and she's roughly tripled
her support there.
And the importance of New Hampshire is maybe
more significant for Bernie Sanders than for
anybody else.
We've talked about this before.
Bernie Sanders is a senator from Vermont,
previously a congressman from Vermont, previously
a mayor of Burlington, Vermont, well liked
by Democrats in New Hampshire merely because
of the proximity of Vermont and New Hampshire.
Back in 2016 Bernie Sanders won easily in
the New Hampshire primary against Hillary
Clinton.
You might recall Bernie got more than 60%
of the vote over Hillary Clinton's 38 and
yet he still didn't win the general primary
and become the 2016 Democratic presidential
nominees.
So when we see Elizabeth Warren surging in
this way in New Hampshire, it is an interesting
monkey wrench.
And there are two opinions about the importance
of New Hampshire.
One view about what's happening in New Hampshire
right now is, listen, Bernie crushed it in
2016 and New Hampshire.
This is the neighbor's state to his home state
of Vermont.
If Bernie doesn't win in New Hampshire, it
bides very poorly for Bernie.
Sandra, it bodes very poorly for Bernie Sanders,
uh, in the broader 20, 20 Democratic primary.
That's one view.
The other view on New Hampshire is it's just
New Hampshire.
Yes, it's an early primary.
Yes, it's close geographically to where Bernie
Sanders, uh, is a senator.
But in the end, it's a very small primary.
It is not actually going to tell us very much
big picture.
Uh, the other view is that it's sort of something
in between.
Now we have to have all of the normal caveats
here.
First of all, number one, yes, Elizabeth Warren
is in first place, but statistically this
is a tie.
It's within the margin of error with Warren,
Bernie and Biden separated in total by only
a couple of points, but the momentum is certainly
going in the direction of Elizabeth Warren.
Number two.
This is also only one poll.
I mean all the other New Hampshire polls still
show, um, Joe Biden ahead gravis or or someone
else ahead rather gravis has Bernie plus six
Emerson has Biden plus three.
However, on the other hand, Warren is pulling
a big lead in New Hampshire as the second
choice for voters.
So aside from reminding us that some version
of ranked choice voting would be a great idea,
consider that 25% of New Hampshire Democratic
primary voters say Warren is their second
choice, followed by Bernie at 17% booted judge
at 13 and then Harrison Biden tied at 12 now
there was something interesting developing
with Elizabeth Warren, not just in New Hampshire
but more broadly and I have been getting emails
from people saying, David, you've got to talk
about this.
Elizabeth Warren is unquestionably becoming
more and more the safe status quo progressive
candidate.
Now what I mean by that is Joe Biden is obviously
the total status quo establishment democratic
candidate.
He straight up told rich donors behind closed
doors.
If I win, nothing.
His substance stuff substantively going to
change for you in terms of your privileged
position in society.
We know that with Biden, Bernie and Warren
are the strong progressive candidates in the
Democratic primary.
Now, I've talked with you before about how
even though on Policy Bernie and Warren ended
up in very similar places, particularly domestic
policy.
Bernie ends up there, pulled right from his,
kind of tear it all down and build it back
up mentality that he comes from Elizabeth
Warren.
On the other hand, ends up they're being pulled
left from her center, left.
Let's make changes to the system and make
it work better for more people faced with
the reality that Joe Biden may fall in the
2020 democratic primary.
I'm reading more and more about Elizabeth
Warren being seen more as the safer to the
status quo, progressive candidate on issues
ranging from healthcare to the financial industry
in taxation and others.
So my question for you today, basically there's
two questions for you today.
Number one, do you believe that this assessment
of Elizabeth Warren is accurate?
In other words, do you see Warren as within
the strong progressive candidates, Bernie
and Warren, the one that is safer to the,
uh, economic, uh, and broader status quo?
Uh, and if you don't tell me why not.
Okay, let me know.
I want to hear from you about this.